[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Lord of the
leaks breaker of news and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you've been keeping up to
date with my Game of Thrones videos then
you'll know that I recently discussed
the rumored prequel that would begin
shooting this month well it looks like
production is full steam ahead now with
our first image of the show coming out
today
HBO shared the photo this morning and it
looks like this show is once again set
to center around Westeros and the north
in it we can see a mysterious character
on horseback who stopped looking over
the kingdom before deciding whether to
travel through the frozen wasteland that
lies ahead of him the show reportedly
titled Blood Moon is apparently set five
thousand years before the events of Game
of Thrones and will be headed up by
Naomi Watson though her specific
character is unknown in addition to this
officially released image fan website
winter is coming also recently dropped
some new behind the scene pictures of
construction work that was being done on
the set in Northern Ireland in these
images we can see what looks to be
elements of the infamous wall as well as
potentially parts of the Night Watch
base I definitely think this would be a
prime location and reportedly the show
will showcase the construction of the
massive Westeros Monument there's also
some elements that many fans think may
be a cave system similar to what the
children of the forest lived in and
there are rumors that the series will
have a large section that shows them
creating a night game whilst these
tidbits are very small is still a lot to
look forward to and I can't wait to see
if this show can save season 8 though I
very very much doubt I'm just gonna stop
talking badly about season a because I'm
sick of it obviously though I'd love to
hear your thoughts on these leaked
images so make sure that you comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure that you check out my
full breakdown of everything we know so
far about the spin-offs which would be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for take the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you